est possible votre ami ne pas regarder
par la fenêtre
oui c'est bon
oui
[Musique]
c'était bon
[Rires]
on se calme en
national s'il vous plaît vous sortez du
véhicule enfin police nationale à
l'accord vous êtes se stationner sur
place pour handicapé là adacore bon ça
va tout de suite un rongeur s'est
rapidement en plus
bouge à éviter ce que vous faites là
l'intérieur pourquoi
si vous voulez que je sorte le carnet de
timbres amendes dans pas longtemps ça va
ça va secouer encore plus
je me rhabille jérôme rouger votre
véhicule je peux la finir
tu peux la finir vous pouvez finir quoi
aggraver savoir les wii vous rhabiller
immédiatement dans sa maison du père
balises d'accord
[Musique]